l'Indre-et-Loire et le Loir-et-Cher sont
placés en vigilance sécheresse depuis le
mois de mars l'objectif est donc de
limiter notre consommation d'eau comment
faire alors pour effectuer certaines
tâches les plus courantes nous avons
suivi une entreprise blezoise qui
propose de laver votre voiture en
utilisant qu'un chiffon et du produit
nettoyant et ça marche reportage
d'Hélène chapelet
200 litres c'est en moyenne la quantité
d'eau consommée pour un lavage au
rouleau si vous optez pour le nettoyage
haute pression en fonction des options
choisies votre consommation peut varier
de 45 à 60 litres même si cette eau est
aujourd'hui majoritairement recyclée
réutilisé il existe une autre solution
encore plus écologique le nettoyage sans
eau c'est le quotidien de Dimitri ce
matin-là à Blois il nettoie l'une des
voitures du parc du conseil
départemental son secret des chiffons
microfibres un nettoyant multi-usage et
pas mal d'huile de coude
on pulvérise le véhicule et on passe à
l'aide d'une chiffonnette on passe une
première fois et après on essuie on
grosso modo on en fait 5 par matinée 5
voir 6 et sur une durée de temps de sa
variée entre 30 et 40 minutes par
véhicule
sur le même parking Fatoumata s'attaque
à une autre voiture et en quelques coups
de chiffon le pare-choc retrouve tout
son éclat
ça m'a donné l'idée aussi pour moi pour
m'avertir nettoyer sa l'eau et c'est
propre mieux même que
cette technique de nettoyage est
proposée depuis 2014 par l'entreprise
Blaise éthique et claire pour nettoyer
l'intérieur et l'extérieur d'une voiture
selon son dirigeant il faudrait
seulement 40 cl de produits dilués on
est donc bien loin de la consommation en
eau des autres solutions de lavage on
nettoie à la fois des vélos et à la fois
des semi-remorque ou du matériel
agricole donc non on nettoie des
véhicules qui sont ou des véhicules de
chasseurs par exemple donc des véhicules
qui sont très très sales non non il y a
pas de
il y a pas de difficulté sur des
véhicules très sales on les nettoie
pour la prestation de base intérieure et
extérieure comptez 35 euros l'assurance
d'avoir fait un geste pour
l'environnement et d'avoir donné un coup
de pouce à des personnes en réinsertion
professionnelle